[Musique]
le 25 janvier 1308 philippe iv le bel
marie sa fille isabelle de france à
edouard deux rois d'angleterre à partir
du 19ème siècle et d'une vision purement
politique de l'histoire
on y voit la cause fondamentale de ce
que l'on commence à appeler la guerre de
cent ans
en fait ce mariage ne servira que le
prétexte au fils aîné qui en sera issu
edouard iii a succédé à son père en 1300
or un an plus tard le dernier fils de
philippe le bel meurt sans héritier et
c'est un cousin que les grands du
royaume choisissent pourquoi choisi par
les barons parce qu'il est français donc
il ya un vrai il peut sentir la un début
de sentiment national personne ne veut
qu'un roi étrangers gouverne la france
on décrète donc seul un homme et non une
femme de transmettre la couronne de
france et le choix de du foot d'un
français alors qu'il doit re 3 est perçu
comme un anglais
et puis c'est aussi le choix d'un prince
qui n'est pas trop puissant c'est à dire
qu'il n'est que compte de valloire et de
quelques autres principauté alors que
l'autre est roi d'angleterre donc entre
un roi qui aurait d'une double couronne
et un roi qui est bon est un prince
parmi d'autres les bars on préfère un
prince normale en quelque sorte
[Musique]
oh
c'est la fin de la dynastie des
capétiens direct philippe de valois fils
de compte devient roi de france tandis
qu'edouard trois fils de roi et petit
fils de philippe le bel est censé lui
rendre hommage
d'un côté on a le futur philippe 6 mme
leneveu de philippe le bel de l'autre on
a le roi d'angleterre qui est le
prétendant le plus proche par sa mère
son fils prétend que sa mère peut lui
transmettre son droit donc à ce titre il
prétend la couronne en réalité il sait
pas vraiment la couronne qu'il souhaite
c'est la souveraineté pleines de
l'aquitaine le vrai enjeu il est là mais
ils demandent plus pour avoir moins on
voit bien dans cette affaire toute la
difficulté qu'il y a depuis toujours
entre les plantagenêts les capétiens
autour du détrône d'angleterre parce que
quand on se réconcilie ont fait des
mariages
mais après il ya des questions
d'héritage donc la guerre de cent ans en
bas c'est l'exaspération de ce sentiment
les causes de cette guerre séculaire
sont beaucoup plus complexes et
nécessitent d'être développées dans ce
premier épisode
ce premier cycle se décompose en deux
principaux temps les victoires anglaises
qui enfonce progressivement la france
dans une grave crise démographique
économique et idéologique
puis les reconquêtes française qui après
une quarantaine d'années de conflits
amène quasiment les deux nations en
cours de construction dos à dos
tandis que la population du royaume de
france avoisine les 17 millions
d'habitants
celle du royaume d'angleterre n'est que
de 4 millions tout autant de producteurs
de soldats et de contribuables en moins
depuis 30 ans le roi de france profite
de sa supériorité pour raboter le duché
d'aquitaine l'aquitaine était vraiment
la terre d'élection des plantagenêt
c'était vraiment la possession anglaise
par excellence mais c'est une écharpe
dans le royaume de france et à tout
moment
cette possession a été remise en cause
il ya eu des des apanages c'est à dire
que un moment on considérait que c'était
une possession anglaise mais qu'il
fallait rendre hommage au roi de france
et puis lorsque la guerre de cent ans a
commencé
les choses se sont envenimées même
réduits il reste une enclave anglaise au
tour de bordeaux et du commerce du vin
les gascons et le roi d'angleterre ont
des intérêts communs
le vin se vend très bien dans l'île et
rapporte des taxes aux finances royales
mais il est temps pour edouard iii de
redonner à bordeaux un arrière-pays sous
peine d'asphyxié cette ville portuaire
en treize 129 il gagne du temps en
rendant officiellement hommage aux
valois qui empiète son territoire lui
vole sa couronne et soutient les
écossais contre son autorité l'hommage
c'est une cérémonie pour laquelle le
vassal s'agenouille et le geste le
principal c'est que il met ses mains
dans les mains de son seigneur mon
seigneur lui prend les mains et dans le
dico nos graphiques médiéval le pouvoir
est dans les mains et donc mettre ces
nains entre ses mains de son seigneur
c'est bien physiquement et
symboliquement manifester sa dépendance
à dire on se remet littéralement dans
les mains de son seigneur ça consiste
après adam des obligations de conseil
dead de son seigneur être entre deux
militaires ou financières et plus
généralement de ne pas nuire à son
seigneur donc c'est la cérémonie qui
règle les rapports entre seigneurs et
vassaux depuis l'an mil jusque jusqu'au
guerre de cent ans
philippe 6 a lui aussi des problèmes
d'autorité avec la flandre se compter
vis du commerce de la laine qui se
développe entre l'europe du nord et la
méditerranée la matière brute dont ont
besoin pour survivre les commerçants les
tisserands et tout le peuple flamand
provient d'angleterre or la crise est
déjà là la famine que l'on avait oublié
de retour
la guerre de cent ans est aussi la
conséquence d'une crise économique
l'occident en pleine expansion depuis
trois siècles connaît une fin de cycle
c'est un monde saturé et qui plonge dans
un conflit politique d'où il ne sortira
que sous la forme d'une renaissance le
moyen âge se prépare à mourir
l'assujettissement de la flandre la
couronne de france devient dramatique
quand en 1337 edouard iii décide de
suspendre les relations commerciales
avec la flandre c'est une province un
peu insoumise un peu turbulente
chroniquement aimé le roi d'angleterre
va exploiter cette faille en
poussant les flamands se révolter contre
leurs hôtes france et grâce à un moyen
économique c'est que l'angleterre
fournit la laine au drapier flamands qui
avaient avec la laine anglais stis du
drap qu'ils exportent dans le monde
entier et donc le tout début de la
guerre de cent ans edouard iii va couper
les exportations de l'inde vers la
france ce qui oblige les flamands à
choisir entre leur fournisseur de
l'aisne où le roi français et
choisissent le fournisseur de l'aisne
donc se révoltent contre le roi français
c'est le représentant des marchands de
la ville de gand qui sommet à edouard
iii l'idée de joindre aux léopards qui
ornent ses étendards et ses blasons des
fleurs de lys ainsi la flandre est
toujours assujettie à la couronne de
france celle que devrait porter celui
qui porte déjà celle d'angleterre edward
est enfin prêt quand il réclame son dû
il a réorganisé son armée du recrutement
à l'armement
la priorité est donnée à l'arc plus
rapide que l'arbalète et qui fait ses
preuves face aux velléités
d'indépendance des écossais après avoir
pacifié sont ils
l'angleterre peut se tourner vers le
continent son rôle fondamental dans le
secteur du textile lui procure l'aide
financière et les soutiens diplomatiques
les investisseurs sont italiens et et
villes le long du rhin pouces l'empereur
germanique à promettre des contingents
cela suffit à philippe qui convoque
edwards et en son absence le condamne à
la confiscation de son duché en
aquitaine c'est donc une guerre féodal
entre deux ambitions et non entre deux
nations même si guerre éminemment
économique la guerre de cent ans et déjà
une guerre entre deux budgets entre deux
monnaies
[Musique]
le peuple et c'est d'empêcher des
chrétiens de se tuer entre eux et
propose une croisade qui n'aura jamais
lieu
l'église est partagé entre deux nations
catholique c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas
encore eu le schisme anglican et donc le
l'église et le pape essaye de jouer un
rôle d'apaisement mais avec des
alliances tantôt avec les uns tantôt
avec les autres
grâce à l'aide de la castille et de la
république de gênes
philippe a préparé une flotte pour la
terre sainte qu'il préfère faire
remonter vers les mers du nord afin
d'établir un blocus à l'encontre de
l'économie anglaise en trés 138 les
marins français se permettent des raids
dans les ports de la côte sud de
l'angleterre entre 139 edouard lance une
première chevauchée à partir du brabant
ils cherchent moins la conquête qu'une
bataille rangée que philippe lui refuse
finalement edouard décide de lever
l'embargo et de défier les forces
navales françaises
le premier affrontement de la guerre de
cent ans à lui en mer du nord en 13140
dans l'avant-port de bruges à lécluse à
la vue de la flotte anglaise les 200
navires chargés du blocus se lie les uns
aux autres pour constituer une muraille
infranchissable
l'amiral décide en fait de faire une
barricade de bateaux pour boucher
l'estuaire du swing qui le la rivière
qui mène à bruges c'était la destination
d'edouard iii
donc ils enchaînent les bateaux groupe
ou sur une ligne qui barre la rivière et
le fleuve concurrence qui barre le
fleuve et qui fait comme une barricade
de bois sur trois rangées ça qui met ses
200 bateaux sur trois rangées en
profondeur comme ça ça fait une grosse
barrière qui est supposée arrêter les
anglais edward attend le vent et la
marée à forces égales
la mobilité et la vitesse vont
rapidement la différence la défaite
française est totale et l'angleterre a
maintenant la maîtrise des mers leroy
france perd sa flotte totalement ce jour
là et surtout c'est une des batailles
les plus sanglantes
de toutes les gares de son temps parce
que les chevaliers en armure en fait
sont tous noyés enfin une fois que les
bateaux sont coulés ou qu'ils tombent à
l'eau il se noie
alors qu'on sur un champ terrestre un
blessé peut survivre alors que la non
abc il faut nous a immédiatement et donc
il ya l'effroyable 17 mondy 17 mille
morts ce qui est le plus pire la pierre
bataille de la guerre de cent ans
mais deux seuls français n'est pas prêt
à accueillir les bras ouverts le roi
d'angleterre
la guerre coûte cher et le 25 septembre
13140 une première trêve et conclu la
guerre coûte cher parce que les vassaux
certes doivent servir gratuitement
pendant 40 jours leur seigneur donc le
roi de france peuvent faire appel à
beaucoup de basso mais quarante jours
c'est très court et ça que ces quarante
jours comment ça partait moment où ils
quittent leur château donc le temps
qu'il se rende à ce qu'il soit un peu
éloigné sur le lieu des opérations déjà
une partie du temps gratuite épuisé et
ensuite il faut attendre les anglais
aller à la bataille et c'est donc en
fait très rapidement le roi est obligé
de les payer de les solder sans compter
des mercenaires qui ne sont pas grâce au
complet dès le début sans compter
l'artillerie ou les coûts de
fortifications enfin bref un coût énorme
qui estimé pour la france à peu près à
trois à cinq millions de livres par an
or le budget du rock france ces cinq
cent mille livres donc ça veut dire
quand il ya la guerre pendant l'année
c'est 3 à 5 x 3 10 fois son budget
annuel tandis que philippe réussit à
systématiser un impôt sur le sel la
gabelle edouard n'arrive pas à
convaincre son parlement qui trouve ses
interventions peu productive la gabelle
et un impôt fondée sur le sel le sel un
rôle extrêmement important
le sel c'est ce qui permet de conserver
les aliments on le faire des salaisons
il y a dans toutes les maisons
françaises ca loire où l'on roule en
concert et donc la possession de sel est
un signe de richesse yonnais du sel
c'est qu'on a de la viande est donc
on fait une carte de france de
l'imposition fondée sur la la détention
de sel
les armées au 14e siècle se
professionnalise
elles sont soldés le paysan sans terre
ou le citadin sans métier devient
soldats et le vassal devient capitaine
quant au suzerain il disparaît pour
laisser la place au soufre à entre les
deux chefs d'état c'est le problème de
succession du duché de bretagne où
chacun soutient son prétendant qui
occupe les esprits à partir de 13 141 la
bretagne en fait reproduit le même
schéma que le problème de succession qui
a abouti à la guerre de cent ans
donc d'un côté on a un charme de blois
le neveu du roi de france
de l'autre on à jean de montfort qui est
l'alliée du roi d'angleterre
c'est ce dernier jean monfort qui va
remporter la victoire
donc la bretagne bascule en partie du
côté anglais 1 et sa veuve poser un
véritable problème pour la france
l'intervention de l'armée anglaise lui
permet d'occuper une partie du duché et
d'installer des garnisons qui reste
autant de nouveaux points d'appui côté
français le trésor royal se vide
philippe convoque alors les états
généraux en 13 143 tous ceux qui jouent
un rôle dans le royaume grands barons
hommes d'église universitaire bourgeois
sont convoqués afin de soutenir l'effort
de guerre
mais la pression fiscale au nom de
l'état n'est pas encore dans les moeurs
un seigneur de normandie joffre
d'harcourt ne suis pas la mobilisation
générale en juillet 13146 ils permettent
à edouard de pénétrer sur le continent
avec une armée de 15 mille âmes c'est la
première grande chevauchée une
chevauchée semaine à cheval mais en
réalité il ya aussi des piétons qui
suivait la chevauchée n'avance pas si
vite à l avance à peu près à 10 15 km
par jour donc les piétons peuvent tout à
fait suivre même si le
les chevaliers sont montées c'est qu'ils
sont sous le regard des commentateurs et
les chroniqueurs l'armée anglaise
répartis en colonne sur plusieurs
kilomètres de large s'enfonce dans le
cotentin en semant la terreur
tu es même gratuitement violé et pillé
afin de renouveler l'intendance
nécessaires à la poursuite de l'action
sont les objectifs d'une chevauchée
cette chevauchée fait en quelque sorte
un une percée du à peu près 5 10 km de
large où ils pillent tout sur leur
passage
le but étant d'appauvrir de faire du
butin le discréditer l'adversaire qui
n'est pas capable de défendre son
royaume
et puis ensuite de repartir en
angleterre couvert de gloire est couvert
d'or après le périple qui dure quelques
mois ce moment sur général ça se fait la
belle saison on débarque en mai juin et
on rembarque en août septembre
en gros c'est ça le le programme pendant
que philippe se prépare à la riposte
l'armée d'edouard se trouve bientôt le
long de la seine paris tremble
l'enceinte du louvre n'est plus adaptée
mais une chevauchée n'est pas une
conquête à la mi août
estimant la démonstration de force
suffisante les anglais remonte vers le
nord
prendre et tenir calais c'est s'assurer
le chemin le plus court pour contrôler
la suite des événements sur le long
terme
les français voient dans le choix
d'éviter paris une preuve de faiblesse
la chevalerie de philippe se lance à la
poursuite des troubles d'edouard
convaincu que la victoire et les
honneurs se trouve au bout de la course
les français sont deux fois plus
nombreux que les anglais la rencontre a
lieu à crécy le 26 août 13146 bataille
de crécy fait partie avec la bataille de
lécluse des premières grandes batailles
de la guerre de cent ans alors c'est une
bataille terrestre extrêmement le dur
cruel
les anglais attendent depuis le matin
l'armée de philippe n'arrive qu'au
soleil couchant accompagné d'un grand
vol de corbeaux
plutôt que d'attendre le lendemain après
s'être reposé et organiser la chevalerie
française et ses alliés se lance team
médiatement à l'assaut
parmi eux le compte de luxembourg jean
l'aveuglent qui personnifie par sa
cécité toute la maladresse de cette
offensive
les français ont le soleil dans les yeux
et face à eux mais aussi sur les côtés
l'infanterie anglaise décoche une pluie
de flèches la noblesse de l'attak ne
peut rien contre l'arc plus léger qui
évite le corps à corps et rend la force
du nombre presque dérisoire
prince de galles fils d'édouard peut
faire charger ses chevaliers c'est
lanciers pour la mise à mort de tous est
aveugle et son père n'a même pas besoin
d'intervenir
on ne sait si l'armure de ce prince
était noir
mais il rentrera dans l'histoire de
france avec ce surnom le prince noir le
prince noir
à l'époque on l'appelle pas du tout
comme ça on l'appelle le prince de
galles et noir domine store ou bien on
l'appelle le prince d'aquitaine c'est un
surnom que lui ont donné les historiens
au xvième siècle comme pour la plupart
des protagonistes un des surnoms sont
très tardif surnom donc dû à son armure
noir ne m'aiment pas plus m'en certain
que ce soit exact mais une histoire la
retenue sous le nom de prince noir à
cause de son armure qui aurait été noir
à la nuit tombée
felip sans sonner la retraite fuit il a
perdu la plupart de ses fidèles ainsi
qu' abandonner sur le champ de bataille
l'oriflamme de saint denis a porté jadis
par un ange afin de symboliser la
mission divine d'un roi qui a été sacrée
philippe si c'est un roi mal aimé des
historiens il a pas beaucoup de
biographies philippe si évidemment on
sait celui des fêtes
la perte de l'aquitaine bon en réalité
j'étais plutôt je trouve un roi qui a
fait preuve d'une certaine sagesse il
n'était pas préparé à ce métier on dit
que c'est le roi chevalier que il
incarne toutes les valeurs de la
chevalerie ce qui est vrai en même temps
il a fait plus proche d'eux plutôt de
sagesse puisque pendant tout le début de
la guerre il refuse les batailles autant
qu'il peut et l'immobilisent l'armée
pour faire sur les anglais mais à chaque
fois qu'il ya une possibilité de faire
la bataille il est prudent il hésite et
en général ça se finit par un compromis
une trêve finalement a créé si on oblige
quasiment à mener fera cesser son armée
presque qu'ils l'oublient je sais la
société politique ses conseillers qui le
pousse à livrer bataille pour enfin
écrasé les anglais alors là c'est une
défaite qui est en grande partie due au
fait que son armée lui obéit mal en fait
une grande indiscipline dans l'armée
française edouard peut alors se
concentrer sur un objectif concret
établir à calais une tête de pont
militaire et commerciale un assaut
coûteux en vies humaines est toujours
aléatoire contre une citadelle
régulièrement entretenus edouard préfère
un siège en bonne et due forme
le triomphe de crécy lui permet de voir
venir un camp et un palais sont montés
en bois entouré d'un fossé est
ravitaillée par un port aménagé pour
l'occasion
l'anglais s'installe les calaisiens sont
eux-mêmes ravitaillés par leurs propres
ports pour tromper l'ennui l'anglais
chevauchent c'est à dire
pis les campagnes dix mois plus tard en
juillet 13 147 edwards s'est décidé à
renforcer le blocus du port de calais
pour en finir
philippe est maintenant obligé de se
montrer mais toutes les entrées
terrestres sont aussi sous contrôle
anglais traverser le moindre pont est
suicidaire
la ville est obligée de capituler afin
d'éviter massacres et viols
et comme edward l'a exigé six bourgeois
viennent en pénitents à porter les clés
de la cité
ce sont des notables de la ville de
calais qui lorsque la guerre de cent ans
se déclarent sont les premiers menacés
par la l'invasion anglais
et lorsque ils s'aperçoivent que leur
ville va être détruite
ils vont faire allégeance au roi
d'angleterre mais pour montrer qu'il
s'agit d'une allégeance contrainte
ils y vont en chemise
sans l'intervention de la reine
d'angleterre
il aurait été sacrifiés pour que
quelques-uns paie la facture un nom de
siège par les temps qui courent engendre
des frais considérables
les banques hésitent à lien d'edouard
ont tous fait faillite il est temps de
rentrer
[Musique]
cependant les bourgeois de calais cette
demi-douzaine d'apôtres du valois
incarne pour longtemps l'humiliation
qu'edouard a fait subir à l'autorité de
la couronne de france
[Musique]
dans l'histoire des batailles il y a un
avant et un après crécy l'importance
stratégique de fantassins prend le pas
sur les prouesses de chevalier la guerre
acquiert une autre spécificité de la
guerre moderne en s'accompagnant d'un
fléau qui en suivant les champs de
bataille va s'abattre régulièrement sur
les hommes pendant l'hiver 13 148 ce
fléau venant d'asie emprunte les routes
commerciales et débarque à marseille
c'est une peste noire d'un bacille qui
donnait la peste bubonique
alors il ya eu des interprétations très
nombreuses pour savoir d'où venait ce
bacille on pense qu'il est venu d'asie
qu'il a été transmis par des guerriers
par des soldats par des marins notamment
on a mis en cause des génois mais on
pense aussi que dans les navires il y
avait des rats et c'est une la peste
bubonique et transmises par les rats le
chrétien d'europe occidentale ne connaît
plus la peste depuis des siècles elle
pénètre rapidement dans les villes qui
favorise la promiscuité tout en
négligeant l'hygiène dans les campagnes
par les troupeaux les basses-cours les
chambres où toute une famille dort
ensemble on sait d'une ville à l'autre
où elle se trouve
et quand elle arrivera
la maladie est devenue une cause énorme
de mortalité c'est entre 30 et 50% de la
population des pays d'occident
qui meurent de la peste b que des traces
brune apparaissent sur la peau il est
trop tard ou comprend la contagion sans
imaginer concrètement ni microbes ni
virus
que faire contre le vent et le besoin de
respirer certains y voient une punition
divine s'organise en procession et se
flagellent au milieu des rues c'est à
partir de la peste noire que l'on voit à
peu près représenter la description des
trois fléaux
c'est à dire la famine la maladie et la
guerre on voit souvent de façon
allégorique et trois personnages qui
représentent les trois fléaux l'ordre et
l'économie sans bouleverser à tel point
que la guerre est interrompue de fait la
population des campagnes a diminué de
moitié de tous les morts ce sont les
enfants qui ne deviendront jamais
parents qui sont les plus préoccupantes
pour la vitalité économique et sociale
de nos deux royaumes
[Musique]
ce n'est pas de la grande peste don
murphy liban 13,150 mais de vieillesse
on les vieux à 57 ans dans ce monde-là
faut dire que c'est une catastrophe son
règne la mesure où les anglais sont très
en position de force
en même temps le patio qu'on ait pu
faire mieux sauf à gagner une bataille
de temps en temps ou à vaincre
tactiquement or c'est très aléatoire ne
peut pas dire que c'est sa
responsabilité personnelle donc au bout
du compte au désarroi qui n'a pas eu de
chance le premier des valois laisse à
son fils jean
un héritage précaire mais élargie au
dauphiné qui devient le pays de galles
de la france
tout comme le fils aîné du roi
d'angleterre prend automatiquement le
titre de prince de galles les dés du roi
en france et le dauphin
jean a appris son métier de roi durant
les 13 dernières années dans un monde en
total déséquilibre
impulsif il s'appuie sur une morale
chevaleresque en train de se consumer
or en raison des échecs de la politique
militaire
la trahison est dans l'air pendant cinq
ans le conflit se limite à l'aquitaine
et surtout à la bretagne où entre deux
sièges de grandes villes une guerre
d'escarmouches et de guet-apens permet
un fils de la petite noblesse bretonne
bertrand du guesclin de faire ses
premières armes
bertrand du guesclin qui est un noble de
bretagne d'une famille très ancienne
tout à fait vénérable mais pas très
argentés qui al'âge de la guerre en
quelque sorte il a 20 ans ou 17 ans au
début de la guerre donc il fait ses
premières armes avec la guerre de
bretagne et se fait remarquer par ses
exploits militaires
remarqué par jean le bond qui le recrute
comme capitaine pour le compte du roi de
france
et puis tout s'accélère à nouveau une
coalition de seigneurs normands se
constitue autour de charles le mauvais
roi de navarre éventuels prétendants à
la couronne de france s'il est émis plus
tôt
sarr le mauvais c'est aussi un surnom
tardy fin du xvième siècle à l'époque on
l'appelle charles de navarre charles de
navarre c'est un membre de la famille
royale en fait il est petit fils de
louis 10 mais il est né entre et 132
c'est à dire qu'il est né quatre ans
après la crise de succession s'il a été
cité n'est entré 128
il aurait dû être roi de france en fait
il c'était le premier mâle en ligne
directe mais il se trouve qu'il n'était
pas encore en est à ce moment là donc il
en a conçu et donc il est né après c'est
un prince de la famille royale qui est
un peu si vous voulez on l'a dit le
mauvais parce que il c'est pas un
mauvais surnom dit c'est un petit peu
peut-être exagéré mais il a il a une
rancune tenace à l'égard de la faisait
valoir dont il considère qu' ils l'ont
spoliées alors la spoliation c'est pas
tellement le fait qu'ils peuvent la
couronne puisqu'il était pas né mais
surtout le fait que on lui à sa famille
et héritière du comté de champagne est
un conte est très riche et les valois
ont trouvé le moyen de récupérer ce
comté pour l'attribuer
d'autres d'autres nobles et donc il
considère qu il a été spolié dans son
héritage
après avoir assassiné le bras droit de
jean le bon charles le mauvais se
rapproche d'un autre charles le fils
aîné du roi le premier dauphin de france
c'en est trop pour jean qui intervient
manu militari lors d'un banquet à rouen
donné par son fils il fait emprisonner
charles le mauvais et décapité quelques
traîtres dont le neveu de geoffroy
d'harcourt ce coup de force de jean le
bon est prématurée et seigneur normand
ligués contre lui n'en font que plus
facilement appel aux anglais mais qu'est
ce qu'un traître
qu'est ce qu'un anglais tandis que les
combats reprennent en normandie
le prince noir parti de bordeaux où il
est chez lui et après une première
chevauchée vers le sud
selon ce vers le nord en mars 13,156
jean le bon arrive à obtenir des états
généraux l'aide nécessaire à
l'organisation d'une armée de trente
mille hommes mais la levée de l'impôt
n'est plus effectué par les hommes du
roi le pouvoir monarchique est sous
contrôle l'impôt normalement n'existe
pas c'est à dire que le roi doit vivre
de ses propres son propre patrimoine
il peut demander à lever un impôt pour
défendre le pays mais c'est négocier
avec le pays justement avec le peuple en
l'occurrence plutôt les élites et cette
négociation est très dur très âpre et en
général c'est donnant-donnant il ya
toujours une contrepartie politique
donc c'est difficile c'est long c'est
les sujets paye de mauvaise grâce donc
c'est compliqué de financer la guerre
longtemps ce qui oblige
leroy souvent à utiliser expédiant comme
des mutations monétaire c'est à dire
qu'ils trichent sur la monnaie pour
pouvoir payer ses soldats en normandie
face à cette armée les anglais préfèrent
fuir
jean le bon on en est que plus
déterminés à punir de descendants des
plantagenêts de traverser son royaume et
par la même occasion à faire oublier
crécy le prince noir ne veut pas d'une
bataille l'objectif est de semer la
panique de désorganiser l'état français
et de conserver des places fortes
les anglais n'ont pas les moyens pour
l'instant d'envisager plus les troupes
du prince noir sont fatigués par un an
de chevaucher les français sont deux
fois supérieures en nombre
si l'affrontement est inévitable en
raison de la détermination de jean le
prince noir a le choix du terrain il
décide d'attendre en haut d'un plateau à
quelques lieux au sud-est de poitiers
le site vallonné rang l'assaut
problématique le dimanche 18 septembre
13,156 malgré l' avantage du terrain
le prince noir propose de restituer le
butin amassé par les pillages et de
signer une trêve malgré la difficulté du
terrain gens refusent la paix du prince
noir et sans que celui-ci le sache
il refuse également d'encercler les
anglais et d'attendre la famille il
attaquera demain la chevalerie française
se prépare en adaptant son équipement
ont vu de terminer la soie pied j'en
sais qu'en envoyant aux avant-postes la
fine fleur de sa chevalerie briser la
ligne de défense anglaise
la plupart ne survivront pas aux flèches
des archers dont le souvenir de crécy en
toutes les mémoires
au petit matin une partie de l'armée
anglaise semble battre en retraite
c'est effectivement le choix du prince
noir à cours de nourriture face à cet
événement inattendu
les vieux réflexes des guerres féodales
reprennent le dessus la chevalerie
française charge sans aucune discipline
sans qu'une seule et même bannière
viennent les guides et face aux métier
des fantassins anglais et de leur prince
noir
les pertes sont déjà importantes quand
il est temps de continuer le combat en
mettant pied à terre au coeur de la
journée
l'équilibré des forces seront dans la
défaite probable j'en demande à son fils
charles de quitter le champ de bataille
l'enjeu ne doit pas devenir la couronne
de france lui restera jusqu à se battre
au corps à corps hache à la main avant
d'être fait prisonnier à la tombée du
jour
alors jean le bon s'appelle le bonze qui
signent pas qu'il et débonnaire
d'ailleurs il n'est même plus tôt
colérique et pas spécialement bon ça
veut dire fort en fait jean le bon c'est
le roi fort le roi brave leroy courageux
il l'a illustré la bataille de poitiers
qu'il n'a pas
fuyez les anglais qui avaient très bien
repéré le roi et qui allait vers lui et
en espérant bien sinon le tuer au moins
le capturer et ainsi régler non
seulement la bataille n'est peut-être
même la guerre de cent ans et lui en bon
chevalier en chevalier parfait et bien
n'a pas reculé il a affronté les anglais
avec une grande bravoure avec son fils
de 14 ans le philippe qu'on a surnommé
le hardi ensuite qui désepère garez-vous
à gauche perd grève ou à droite moment
célèbre une grand moment de la vie
chevaleresque mes moments pitoyable de
la vie politique puisque il est capturé
il est présenté au prince noir les deux
cousins se voient pour la première fois
la nouvelle du désastre plonge le
royaume au bord du gouffre heureusement
pour les valois l'investissement anglais
sur le continent ne peut se poursuivre
faute de moyens et les résultats sont
jugés suffisants jean le bon captifs à
londres et doivent entamer des
négociations en position de force
les onglets letienne est désormais non
seulement vont le rançonner à 4 puis il
en a b c 3 millions d'écus mais surtout
il ya plus personne pour gouverner le
royaume de france un son fils n'est pas
réjean il n'a aucune légitimité à
gouverner parce que son père est
toujours vivant et jean claude lebon
prétend gouverner la france depuis
l'angleterre il est prisonnier à
bordeaux puis à londres et la haye
l'envoi des courriers en disant voilà il
faut nommer un tel à tel endroit vous
allez faire ceci avec les impôts vous
allez faire la paix avec l'angleterre
enfin bref il fait toute une politique
mais une politique qui est plutôt qui
n'est pas acceptée en france parce
qu'elle est destinée à le libérer en
fait donc lui il est prêt à tout céder
aux anglais pour être libérés or en
france le dauphin les conseillers la
société politique refuse de payer une
rançon à 4 millions d'euros
refuge surtout de céder quoi que ce soit
aux anglais et donc il ya une fin à un
moment très grave une très une crise
politique très grave entre 13,156 et
très 169 pendant quatre ans il ya plus
de chef à plus de tes chefs à la tête du
royaume
heureusement pour le royaume
charles le dauphin et plus diplomate que
batailleur
ce sens de la diplomatie va lui être
particulièrement utile pour gérer les
affaires intérieures la guerre va
effectivement devenir civile
les bourgeois de paris viennent d'élire
comme représentant etienne marcel comme
celle de tous les bourgeois les affaires
détiennent mars elle souffre de l'état
de guerre mais il fait aussi partie de
ces ambitieux qui s'estiment lésés par
les valois ceux-ci se montrant incapable
de gérer la crise
c'est l'occasion de proposer une
alternative et de se venger
etienne marcel était le prévôt des
marchands c'est à peu près qui veulent
en ce qu'est le maire de paris un
personnage politique considérable qui
est un rôle important dans le royaume
[Musique]
etienne marcel s'érige en véritable
contre-pouvoir
il contrôle les finances du royaume par
le biais de son influence aux états
généraux ainsi que la défense de la
capitale par le biais de son charisme
sur les compagnons et boutiquiers
parisien
[Musique]
étienne leur distribue des chaperons
rouges et bleus et leur rend l'espoir en
proposant une réforme de l'état où le
monarque serait conseillé par des
représentants des états généraux
la situation du dauphin se complique
avec l'évasion de charles de mauvais en
13 157 parle de navarre va toujours être
du côté des anglais un ça va être
l'allié naturel des anglais contre les
valois et à chaque fois qu'il veut et
les choix qui va pouvoir il va mettre
toute son énergie à nuire aux valoir pas
tellement pour prétendre à la couronne
mais surtout pour augmenter ses
seigneurie parce qu'ils les
possessionnais on peut en normandie en
fait un décompte d'evreux il possède une
partie du cotentin de grosses des gros
territoire on entendit donc en gros ça
ça son objectif c'est une forme
d'autonomie en normandie mis en navarre
ou ne va rien y est roi et des
indépendants mais une forme d'autonomie
dans le royaume avec une la plus grosse
principauté possible avec l'appui des
anglais contre les valois en l'absence
du roi les intérêts de tous et ambitieux
pourrait converger etienne marcel
profite à fond de la situation
sous son impulsion le 22 février 13 158
une émeute se finit dans le palais royal
deux des principaux conseillers du
dauphin sont exécutées sous ces cieux
charles le dauphin fuit paris
ne manque plus que l'adhésion des villes
de province pour qu etienne marcel
exerce totalement le pouvoir avec ou
sans charles le mauvais mais c'est une
révolution parisienne les villes de
province ne bouge pas les campagnes par
contre se met à bouger sans ketin mars à
lille soit pour quoi que ce soit en
ville les gens des campagnes s'incarne
en jacques bonhomme
le paysan dont on note les moeurs voir
la bestialité
pourquoi les jacks et bien parce que
lorsque les les nobles parle des paysans
et des appels jacques ou jacques
bonhomme entre on voulait traduire en
c'est très méprisant 1
si on traduit en langage contemporain
c'est juste le péquenot en fait en
maîtresse 158 partie d'une bagarre dans
un village de picardie un mouvement de
petits propriétaires terriens se met en
marche
le mouvement grossi de village en
village de bouche à oreille on est entré
158 en maître sur 58 points au moment
pile de cette crise politique provoquée
par la capture de jean le bon son fils
charles qui est dauphin essayer de
négocier avec les états généraux un
impôt pour payer une armée pour faire la
guerre aux anglais les états généraux
etienne marcel menée par etienne marcel
refusent ou plutôt exige des
contreparties politiques extrêmement
lourd enfin bref une situation très très
difficile
finalement ils s'accordent sur
la possibilité d'un impôt qui est mal
payés mal logés donc c'est la solution
n'est pas résolu et surtout charles 5 et
donne l'ordre à tous les seigneurs de
fortifier leur château pour se préparer
à une éventuelle chevauchée en anglais
et donc c'est ça qui va être le
déclencheur de la révolte en fait
pourquoi parce que les seigneurs
répondait mais comment voulez vous qu'on
défend même qu'on mette en défense nos
châteaux ça coûte cher de reconstruire
les remparts de fortifier les tours etc
et le roi leur donne le droit de taxer
leurs paysans et c'est la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase en fait et les
paysans refusent
désespéré par les souffrances endurées
depuis des décennies et scandalisé par
l'incompétence et l'arrogance de ceux
qui ont pouvoir et argent lesjak tulle
et noble qu'il rencontre femmes et
enfants est ce que font les jacky et
bien ils se révoltent contre leur propre
seigneur et ça donne lieu à des
lynchages en fait et ils prennent
d'assaut le château par surprise enfin
c'est un c'est en quelque sorte attaqué
pour ne pas être attaqué c'est comme ça
qu'ils voient les choses se disent on va
être réquisitionnée on va nous prendre
tous nos biens
on attaque le seigneur avant qu'ils nous
prennent tous nous bien des années de
frustration les pousse à faire durer le
supplice n'ayant plus ni foi ni loi il
se dirige vers paris c'est la terreur
tous les gens de bien compte sur charles
le mauvais pour rétablir l'ordre
quant à etienne marcel il est emporté
dans son élan et donne son soutien ou
jacques le 9 juin
les hommes de charles le mauvais étouffe
la révolte en massacrant les jacques hy
les meilleures troupes détiennent marcel
une fois qu'on a pris le château et
qu'on a tué le seigneur violé sa femme
et ses filles évidemment là il n'y a pas
de c'est un point de non-retour en
quelque sorte et pas de pardon possible
donc après il ce groupe
l'alerté donnée donc ça circule de
clocher en clocher avec les toxines en
quelque sorte ils se regroupent en armes
et paysannes et les nobles franciliens
eu deux passé le premier moment de
surprise se regroupent aussi en armée
est évidemment la bataille est inégal
puisque là c'est le pot de terre contre
le pot de fer au sens littéral et ils
sont écrasés à la bataille de mélo en
juin 358 et après il ya plus de
jacquerie pour arriver à un tel résultat
charles le mauvais enrôlent des anglais
de la haine de l'anglais à la haine du
traître et à l'amour du drapeau
il n'ya qu'un pas une émeute favorable
aux dauphins est utilisée pour mobiliser
tous ceux qui sont fatigués par cette
guerre civile les ennemis détiennent
marcel en finisse définitivement avec
lui le 10 août
charles réintègre la capitale
reste que c'est celle de son père dont
on ne peut obtenir la libération tant
les exigences des douars sont
inacceptables
[Musique]
de calais à la navarre le royaume de
france devrait faire une croix sur sa
façade maritime l'impôt pour la guerre
et le bien commun n'en ai que d'autant
plus facilement levé
les douars débarque à nouveau pour une
chevauchée qui le conduit à reims
charles dauphin y a concentré ses
troupes
charles septembre il edwards ne peut se
permettre financièrement un siège aussi
long qu'à calais
il voit ses prétentions à la baisse en
13 160 un accord est conclu à brétigny
[Musique]
edouard liberge ans et renoncent à la
couronne de france les gens renoncent à
recevoir l'hommage des douars pour
l'aquitaine qui est rattaché directement
à l'angleterre
les princes prête serment sur des
reliques des rois signent le traité à
calais mais les changes des
renonciations est remise à plus tard
quand chaque camp aura prouvé sa bonne
volonté
ce traité se situe entre deux âges et
cette paix précaire annonce de nouvelles
échéances
le compromis a été trouvé avec edouard
iii qui acceptent de renoncer à sa
prétention à la couronne donc les bâlois
sont bien les rois légitime de la france
c'est là le petit pas que je fais
edouard iii mais en échange il obtient
ce qui probablement vous voulez
l'essentiel il obtient la souveraineté
totale sur l'aquitaine et non seulement
l'aquitaine mais l'aquitaine très
largement comprise en fait elle déborde
largement sur le massif central
donc c'est beaucoup plus que bordeaux et
sa région c'est tout le quart sud ouest
de la france devient anglais sans ne
rien devoir sans obligation féodal par
rapport au roi de france donc ça c'est
là le principal principales clauses plus
une rançon pour le roi jean pour la
libération du roi jean qui prisonniers à
londres 2 3 millions d'écus même durant
les trêves la guerre ne s'arrêtent pas
pour le peuple
les mercenaires qu'il soit à la solde
des anglais ou des français profite des
périodes de paix pour échapper à tout
contrôle s'organisent tant compagnie
pour piller tuer et violer
ce sont ces bandes hors la loi qui vont
susciter durablement la haine de la
guerre dans un premier temps puis celle
de l'ennemi anglais dans un second temps
et ainsi favoriser le sentiment
d'appartenance à une nation française
à la question qu'est ce qu en anglais
c'est tout d'abord le peuple de france
qui apporte une réponse
l'anglais c'est l'étranger qui sèment le
chaos
c'est seulement après que l'état
français et ses légiste invoque la loi
salique celle des francs saliens de
clovis afin d'exclure les femmes de la
succession à la couronne de france
et de justifier qu'elles soient sur la
tête du valois
philippe 6 était un natif du royaume le
royaume devient nation et la nation a
besoin d'ordre et ce n'est que plus tard
encore que le prince noir incarnera tous
ceux qui se posent à la nation française
charles a donc l'appui du peuple quand
il devient cher le 5
en treize 164 surnommé le sage il va
trouver son parfait complément ans
bertrand du guesclin
ces deux hommes ont le même objectif est
facile ardoise de crécy de poitiers de
brétigny et leurs conséquences
matérielles et idéologique
c'est un des acteurs principaux de la
guerre première partie de la gamme en
200 ans parce qu'il a vécu en fait assez
longtemps il a commencé jeune il a vécu
longtemps et donc qu'il a été être les
étapes jusqu'au sommet faisant en son et
en plaçant une belle ascension sociale
puisque il est parti je partais les
moyennes ne blesse pas très l'argenté
est finie connétable couvert de gloire
récompensé par le roi charles reprend en
main la levée de l'impôt la monnaie
frappée par le roi redevient stable
langage et peut avoir confiance en sa
solde l'entraînement au tir à l'arc est
encouragée tout le système des
fortifications et réadapté ont construit
une nouvelle bastille à paris tout
autant pour prévenir les troubles
extérieure qu'intérieure chaque denier
investi dans la guerre est rentabilisé
en étant placés sur des actions sur
faire taire les prétentions de charles
le move et limiter l'influencé anglaise
en bretagne obtenir l'alliance avec la
castille
malgré les chevauchées anglaise les
batailles sont évités
contrairement aux valois qui ont régné
charles acquiert une réputation
d'invincibilité
grâce à cette gestion rigoureuse et
grâce à du guesclin ce meneur d'hommes
est plus un stratège militaire qu'un pro
chevalier
il utilise la ruse pour s'emparer sans
préavis de places fortes simule la fuite
pour mieux contre-attaquer avec ces
soldats embusqués
il confie des responsabilités au mérite
sans se soucier de la naissance c'est ce
genre de principe qui permet aux petits
barons bretons de faire carrière
après une première étape où l'adversaire
est usée très progressivement sans coup
d'éclat mais avec une terrible
efficacité
une deuxième étape plus ambitieuse se
met en place il suffisait d'attendre
cela dit ça les jambes et très
disproportionnée par rapport aux faits
c'est à dire qu'il a gagné des batailles
ne me suis pas mal perdu il a été
rançonné deux fois à chaque fois ça a
coûté une fortune au trésor au royal
parce que c'est le roi qui a payé la
rançon à 40 mille écus soixante mille
écus à fait considérable mais il a aussi
gagné au moins une bataille décisive ca
cocherel et la bête
charles de navarre il a vraiment sauvé
sauver la couronne à cette bataille pour
les anglais ces marchands la guerre et
la gestion administrative d'un
territoire aussi complexe coûte plus
qu'elle ne rapporte protéger la grande
bretagne
calais le sud-ouest de la france est une
situation qui sur le long terme est
source de tensions en particulier avec
le prince noir responsable de
l'aquitaine et haute en fin stratège sur
le champ de bataille que gestionnaire
maladroit et dont la brutalité marque
les esprits
il fait lever des impôts pour
contrecarrer les projets d'alliance
entre la france et la caste il lorsqu'il
est prince d'aquitaine c'est comme ça le
titre que lui donne son père donc il est
vice roi en quelque sorte d'angleterre
mais pour l'aquitaine donc pour l'école
le continent d'un très grand d'aquitaine
conquise après le traité de brétigny et
là il écrase ses sujets d'impôts pour
financer la guerre d'espagne pour
financer aussi une cour très brillante à
bordeaux et se rend impopulaire est en
quelque sorte il est l'artisan de sa
propre perte puisque ça pousse les
gascons à faire appel le roi de france
et à relancer la guerre entre 169 370
donc c'est un peu l'erreur politique il
aurait fait les barons akitani trouvent
pas leur compte ils font appel au roi de
france pour arbitrer le différend qui
les oppose au prince noir selon l'esprit
de brétigny ses vassaux ne dépendent
plus de lui
mais les juristes de charles sont
formels le duché d'aquitaine n'a pas ces
termes et matériellement roi
d'angleterre au cours d'une cérémonie
qui doit se dérouler en aquitaine un
traité signé à calais n'a aucune valeur
l'esprit de brétigny voit la
superposition d'une logique médiévale
l'honneur liées au respect d'un serment
et d'une logique moderne
la raison d'état c'est elle qui va
pousser charles lesage a déclenché de
nouvelles hostilités
s'ils ne répondent pas à l'appel des
bars aux aquitains l'aquitaine est
officiellement anglaise en 13 169 le
prince noir est cité à comparaître en
son absence qui ne surprend personne
son duché est confisqué du coup edouard
reprend le titre de roi de france les
français relancent leurs vieux alliés
écossais la reprise de la guerre est
inévitable et le prince noir est malade
l'armée française a été réorganisé sur
des bases saines
la stratégie est défini par un véritable
état-major le roi ses frères et les
principaux chefs militaires
la discipline et de rigueur et on peut
se permettre d'enrôler les compagnies de
pillards de 13 170 à 13 172 la
reconquête de l'aquitaine progresse
place forte
par place forte l'alliance avec la
castille permet de reprendre le contrôle
des mers en 13 172 aux abords de la
rochelle une flotte anglaise écoulée la
politique navale de charles casse le
business anglais et favorise
outre-manche en même temps que le
sentiment national une conscience
insulaires pour survivre l'angleterre se
doit d'avoir la maîtrise des mers entre
175 une nouvelle progression française
en aquitaine réduit de nouveau les
possession anglaise l'année suivante
meurt le prince noir
il précède d'un non son père dans la
mort il restera le prince noir
les célèbres pendant la première partie
de la guerre de son temps parce que il a
été très vite associé au trône
donc c'est laisser d'héritier donc le
trompèrent lefort me suis son éducation
de très près et en particulier il est
associé à la guerre de france à 16 ans
il est à la bataille de crécy et il
commande un corps d'armée la bataille de
crécy qui est une grande première grande
victoire des anglais en france il aurait
dû être
edouard iv sauf que il est mort avant
son père et donc il n'a jamais renier
c'est son fils qui devient à 10 ans
richard 2 tout ce qu'ils avaient été
perdus depuis 40 ans a été reconquis
honneur et territoires quand meurt en 13
180 charles 5 et son ami du guesclin
tous deux reposent à saint denis
le nouveau roi de france charles 6 à 11
ans débute donc les règnes de deux
enfants rois c'est alors une parenthèse
de près d'un quart de siècle qui s'ouvre
la guerre respire les protagonistes ont
besoin de souffler les moyens ne sont
plus suffisants en particulier avec les
conséquences démographiques de la peste
noire sur les générations suivantes qui
elles aussi ont à affronter des
épidémies moins virulente mais qui
viennent frapper régulièrement
[Musique]